hi everyone I'm Leon fibish and first I
want to thank you all for joining my
talk
today we are going to talk about
detecting anomalous sequences using text
processing methods
try reading that sentence
sounds weird right
and here is the original sentence I
wanted to say hi everyone great to see
you all in my talk
these two sentences have the same words
but when changing the order of the words
like in the first sentence it just looks
weird and makes no sense
so detecting anomalous sequences is a
common problem well you need to
distinguish between normal sequences and
the weird ones
this example is related to text to text
sentences
to stack sequences which are sentences
but there are a lot of type of sequences
basically it's any collection of items
that organized in a certain order and
that the position of each item has a
meaning
you can also think about sequences of
actions system logs events and so on
the field we are focusing in our team is
information security and detecting the
normal of sequences of events or actions
in that field is really important since
detecting changing in the behavior of
the users could be critical for the
organization and we need to detect it as
soon as possible
so we need to find a way to build a
model that will be able to do that
separation between the normal and the
anomalous sequences
as I said before I am Leon fibish I'm a
data scientist on PayPal for almost six
years I am part of the cyber security
threat oversight term which is part of
the information security organization
or a team of security researchers or
each one has a different perspective and
unique point of view in order to cover
as many security issues as possible
my role is finding machine learning
solutions for information security
problems in addition I have MSC in
information systems and software
engineering from Bangor University
so as I mentioned earlier our goal is
detecting anomalous sequences which
means to detect unusual sequences of
items or events
for example if we are looking on those
on those two sentences where one looks
normal and the other one looks weird we
would love to distinguish between those
two sentences and that our model will
will be able to say that this sentence
is a good sentence
and the other one is not
in this talk I'll show you the
architecture I used for detecting for
detecting the anomalies and I'll talk
about the algorithms I used for that
mission which are lower to back bird and
Auto encoders
I'll show you how you can use them for
building the full architecture from
processing the sequences to detecting
the outliers
later I'll show you the experiment I
made how and and how you can use this
architecture for text sequences and also
for sequences of actions that relies to
the information security domain
so let's start with the architecture of
the method
the architecture are used for that
mission included two phases
the first step is modeling the sequences
and the second step is finding the
anomalies
in the first step we would like to
create a vector representation of the
sequence data we want to take that
sequence of items or events and convert
it to some numeric vectors that we will
be able to use in the second step
the way I wanted to do so is using text
processing methods such as wall to vac
and build
in the second step we want to take the
vector we extracted on the first step
and try in a model that learns the
structure of the good sequences and
identifying the anomalies
the model we chose for that mission is
Auto encoders
let's do a quick overview on those
algorithms
in the text processing world the most
common algorithm is wall to work
this algorithm is using neural networks
to learn World associations from a
corpus of text
and as you can understand from its name
each word represented by a vector such
that the similarity between those
vectors indicates the level of
similarity between those words
is also able to capture semantic and
syntactic relations
for example in the words Vector space
the relation between king and queen is
the same as the relation between men and
women
and the relation between big and biggest
is the same as the relation between
small and smallest
this model is context independent which
means that there is only one vector per
word so different senses of the same
word are combined into one single vector
the two models architectures that work
to work utilize are sibo continuous bag
of words and Skip ground and the
difference between them is that in
simple the model predicts the current
world based on this context which is the
words next to it in the sentence and in
skip gram the model is trying to predict
the context which is the words next to
it based on the current world
in Python there is an implementation of
this algorithm in the Gen Sim library
and you can use it to build a
work-to-back model
another text processing algorithm is
built bi-directional encoder
representation from Transformers
birth is a language model that was
bi-directionally trained and can learn
deeper context from language than single
Direction models
best embeddings are context dependent
which means that birds generates context
over embedding that allow for multiple
representations of each word based on a
given words context
and since birth generates contextual
embeddings the input of that model is a
sequence a sentence rather than a single
word and we can get one vector that
represents the entire sentence
Bert was pre-trained in two tasks mask
language modeling MLM where we are
masking some of the tokens which are the
words and we are trying to predict them
from the context and the other one is
next sentence prediction or given two
sentences A and B the model is trying to
predict the probability that sentence B
will appear after the sentence a
the full structure of birds includes
Transformers attention positional
encoding and so on and it is not in the
scope of that presentation and you can
read about it later
in Python you can use the Transformers
library for both using the predefined
birth and for turning a new one from
scratch
okay so now that we have a vector
representation of the sequences we can
move to the next phase which is learning
the structure of the good data and
detecting the anomalies
to do so we are using Auto encoders
Auto encoders are neural networks that
use to learn an efficient encoding of
unlabeled data
it includes two phases encoding the data
and decoding it
so the final output should be the same
or as close as possible to the input
so Auto encoders are trying to minimize
this reconstruction loss
in order to use this architecture for
anomaly detection we are training the
autoencoder on the normal data so when
the model is fully Trend it knows how to
encode and decode regular data and if
there is another structure of data that
looks differently from the regular data
it would interrupt the flow and the
results of the model
so if there is an input of a good data
the Reconstruction loss should be low
and if there is an anomaly the
Reconstruction loss should be high
because the model was turned on normal
data
in Python in order to build the auto
encoder I used Keras in tensorflow
when dealing with sequences there is a
unique type of neural networks that
called RNN recurrent neural networks so
in order to deal with our sequences we
need to build an RNN Auto encoder
but the main challenge here is that each
sequence has a different length for
example each sentence consists of
different words
so we need to build the autoencoder in a
way that it could handle different
lengths of sequences
there are few options to do so
the first option is truncating the
sequences into a predefined size so all
sequences will have the same size
but in this option we are losing data
because we are cutting the sequences and
in a long sequences we are losing a lot
of data
the second option is to use padding
which means to pair the sequences adding
zeros or a predefined value in the
beginning or in the end of the sequence
in order to make all sequences to be in
the same size
but this solution creates long tail of
credit values for short sequences and it
can bias the results of the model
so the next option could be using engram
which means to split the sequence into
few smaller sequences
but the downside of that solution is
that we are losing the meaning of the
full sequence and the connection between
the beginning of the sequence to its
ending
so the last option is adding a masking
layer which means to use padding and
tell the model that this part of the
sequence isn't actually part of the real
sequence and it should skip it when
turning and testing the model
this solution is a bit challenging since
the structure of RNN Auto encoders can't
handle the regular masking layer because
of its encoder decoder structure
when forwarding the sequences along the
encoder and getting to the middle layer
that creates an encoded representation
of the sequence the masking layer is
lost during that compression so there is
a need to create a custom middle layer
that node house that knows how to deal
with masking and forward it to the
decoder
it's possible but it's a bit more
difficult and require some changes in
the code you can read more about using
the masking in Arena to encoder after
this presentation
in our method we decided to combine
padding masking and engram so we will be
able to support all sizes of sequences
we are using padding and masking during
the training phase
and we are using the engram when there
is a new sequence length in the testing
phase that doesn't appear in the
training phase so we are splitting it
into few smaller sequences
examples for using wall to work with
iron and autoencoder could be as for us
the following
suppose we are having the following
sentence hello how are you
would want to work each word is
represented by a vector and the sentence
is a sequence of vectors
for example the word hello is
represented by the vector 0.1 0.8 1.2
0.5 and 1.9
this sequences of vectors are then fed
into the trained RNN autoencode into the
encoder and the decoder layers and at
the end we have the Reconstruction loss
and if its value is high it's an anomaly
and if it flow it's normal
and in this case since since the
sentence looks perfectly fine the
Reconstruction loss should be low
so at the end we are having two options
One is using work to work and RNN
autoencoder and the second option is
using Bear Tooth regular Auto encoder
since birth can produce one vector per
sentence and there is no reason to use
DNR and another encoder and we can use
the regular one
so now after talking about the
architecture of the method we can move
to the second part of the presentation
which is the experiments I made in order
to prove the accuracy of both methods
in order to test both methods we did the
following test that uses text sequences
as input
we use the data set that contains tweets
about the Avengers endgame movie
this data set is taken from kaggle and
you can find it online
we just needed to clean it a bit remove
hashtags and such from the original text
in the first scenario we used we used
work to work in Diagon and autoencoder
so we split those sentences into train
and test set and we trained a
work-to-back model on the transit and in
the work to workspace each word in the
data set is represented by a vector
for example the word Tor is represented
as the following Vector with 10 values
another example of four to work vectors
is that if we are looking on the vectors
of the word tall Iron Man Loki Widow and
Captain we are saying that their vectors
are found close to each other since all
our characters in the movie
and the vector of the world Hammer
swallowed glove weapons and blight are
also found close to each other since all
are type of weapons
so after training the wall to work we
need to train the RNN Auto encoder so we
are taking the output of the wall to vac
which are the encoded vectors the
sequences
and we are building there in an
autoencoder and after training the model
we have a reconstruction loss for each
sequence
so in order to test the full
architecture of the wall to work we
created three types of sentences
the first sentence is the original
sentence for example Avengers endgame is
a masterful epic a true culmination of
22 films that not only concludes the
story but expand upon it and wow what an
ending
so that would be our first sentence the
second sentence is the same sentence
just the words are shuffled
and the third sentence is half the same
as the original sentence and only its
second half is shuffled
we gave the model those three sentences
and we calculated the Reconstruction
loss
as you can see in the histogram the loss
of the original sentence was lower than
the other two sentences the shuffled in
the half-shuffled
which means that the model was able to
identify the original sentence and
separate it from the anomalous sentences
so we did the same experiment with 1000
sentences and we calculated the loss
compared to the original sentences
we considered four scenarios sentences
consist of random words
sentences consist of half real sentence
and half random words
the same sentence but chaffet and half
real sentence and have shuffled and we
calculated the AUC
the AUC for the first scenario was 90
for the second scenario it was 87 for
the third scenario there you see was 86
and for the last scenario which is the
closest as possible to the original
sentence the AUC was 75.
so we also wanted to test that this data
set using the Build architecture
we use the pre-trained bird model and
tokenizer using the following code and
we took the output of the build model
which is one vector per centers and we
built a regular Auto encoder for the
anomaly detection phase
better tokenizer is working as follow
each sentence is converting to a list of
tokens that represents the sentence
it's not necessarily that each word is
represented as a token since birth
worked with subwords and can split one
word into few tokens
the first token is the CLS token which
is the classification token and it's
there to represent the sentence level
classification
and the last token is the sub token
which is the separation token that uses
to separate between sentences
later those tokens are the input to the
birth model and its output has two
parameters the last hidden State and the
polar output
the last hidden state is the sequence of
hidden States at the output of the last
layer of the model
and polar output is the last layer
hidden state of the first token of the
sequence which is the classification
token after further processing two
delays used for the auxiliary
pre-training test
for our task we are using the polar
output as the vector representation of
the sequence
and now we have one vector
representation per sentence and that
would be and that would be the input for
our autoencode
so now we have our belt model and
autoencoder that generates the
Reconstruction loss and we can move on
with our experiment
and if we are going back to our
experiment where we test the different
types of sentences
so here we tested three out of the four
scenarios we used in the previous
experiment
we ignored the fully random sentences
because we felt it was too easy for the
model and doesn't reflect our mission
so we tested they have real sentences
and half random the shuffle sentences
and they have foil and half-shuffle
sentences
there you see was 90 for the half random
sentences 88 for the shuffle scenario
and 84 they have Shuffle sentences
and compared to the wall to vac method
in this case with the Avengers endgame
to its data sets but with regular water
encoder was outperformed the work to
work with RNN Auto encoder
so that was an example with text
sequences
but what if we had a scenario of other
type of sequences
so now after testing this architecture
we take sequences we can move to the
real reason I created this architecture
which is detecting anomalous sequences
that relies to the information security
domain and in this case it's sequences
of actions
so the next scenario is related to the
information security domain and this is
the most interesting part of our
research
we have a system where we have accounts
and users and the users can perform
actions on the accounts
for example actions like login logout
change details see the account details
and so on
let's say that session is a sequence of
events from login to logout
so we want to be able to detect user a
user who performs a normal recessions
and doing Google sequences of actions on
the system
each action by itself is okay but an
anomalous sequence of actions could be
dangerous and it is critical to the
organization for to the organization to
detect those sequences on time and
prevent unauthorized actions
in this case the method we chose is is
using wall to work and RNN autoencoder
and the reason we chose this method is
because it was the first architecture we
thought about and only later we thought
about using burnt
so for training the work-to-back model
on the sessions data set we model each
action of the world and a sequence of
actions was a sentence
we fed those sequences into the world to
vac model and the sequences of vectors
are fed into the RN Auto encoder so now
we have a reconstruction loss for each
sequence and that score can indicate how
normal or abnormal a session is
we trying the data on 30 days of
sessions and we tested it on seven days
we also have examples of two-bed actors
who we know for sure that performed bad
session on several accounts and we
wanted to see this course the model gave
to those real cases and if the model was
able to separate those scenarios from
the rest of the data
so we calculated the request the
Reconstruction loss for the test set and
we plotted the results on The Following
histogram
so this is the histogram of the
Reconstruction loss on the test set and
if we are doing zoom in from 0 to 1 we
are saying that most of the results have
a loss between 0 to 0.2
okay so that's the last of the test set
but what does it mean
now let's look on the histogram of the
first known bed actor which we know for
sure that performed bad sessions on
several accounts
its distribution looks almost the same
as the tested but if we are focusing on
the highest values we are seeing some
interesting results
so if we are focusing on the sessions
with the highest loss and we are
investigating those accounts we say that
some that those accounts indeed were
involved with bad behavior
we start those accounts so different
accounts got different colors
and as you can see almost all of the
sessions of the Reconstruction loss
above 0.2 was by the counts which means
that those sessions were indeed
anomalous and the model was able to tag
them as anomalies and identify that
their structure was different from the
rest of the sessions
so now let's look at the second reducer
and again also in this case almost all
of the sessions that received a lost
above 0.0 was related to bad accounts
this means that this means that our
model indeed was able to recognize the
anomalies sessions again
and if we are looking back in the test
set and plot and putting a threshold of
0.2 will stand with around five percent
of the results
of course that since the size of the
data set could be really big it isn't
enough to filter out 95 of the results
because we are still stand with a lot of
events to track
but if we are adding more constraints on
the sessions like if the type of the
actions are sensitive or if you are
looking on the user's history or the
account history or if we are combining
this method with other alerts we can
reduce the results and the false
positive right even more
so now we have a system that gets us
input all of the actions that has been
made on the account which are the
sessions we mentioned earlier
process it through the model and
generate a score for each action for
each session
this call indicates how normal or
abnormal this session is
and according to the threshold we are
setting based on the results of the
model we can decide if this session is
an anomaly or not
if the score is above that threshold
it's an anomaly and if it's below the
threshold it's a normal session
our first Next Step will be testing the
sessions data set with the Build
architecture and compare the results
with the work to vacuums
later we can also use this architecture
for other tasks for example we can
extract features for for each sequence
and use it for other tasks like
classification or clustering and learn
more about the connection between the
between the sequences
for example we can cluster the sessions
we talked about into several clusters
and see which users are acting alike and
maybe connecting a collaboration between
them
so for conclusions we talked about how
we can detect anomalous sequences that
their structure looks differently from
the other sequences
we saw how we can use text processing
methods such as work to work or build in
order to create featured vectors out of
the sequences
and we also showed how we can use Auto
encoders both regular and RNN
for learning the structure of the good
data and detecting the outliers
we demonstrated this architecture on
road test and non-text data sets and we
showed how we can train the model on
both fields and how the model indeed was
able to detect the outliers in both
cases
thank you for listening to my talk if
you have any questions please feel free
to reach out to me thank you
great thank you Lauren for the very very
nice talk and thank you for leaving some
time as well for the Q a
um I so the audience members for
participating uh chat and viewing it
feel free to leave your questions in the
comments I'll be moderating them and
also subset to Lira
okay
I'll do it
just to see the arms in the chat okay
you see the chat and I'll try to answer
the that's right uh the best I can
that's right that's right so let me help
you with one so there's a question about
uh in the mirror I will bring it up on
screen so that we can have a look
um how do you determine the threshold
when actually deploying these models it
was 0.2 in a test set like when it's a
sequence label as a normal set inference
time just based on these two
observations
okay since uh the field I'm working on
in PayPal I can't tell too much because
it's still information security but
basically the threshold is I'm defining
the threshold based on the data sets and
based on the the sensitivity of of the
data like I'm talking to the team who's
responsible on the alerts and like
according to their
comments were setting the threshold
because if it's too sensitive we want to
set the threshold uh lower so we get
more alerts but it is if it's not that
sensitive we can create a higher
threshold so we'll get less alerts so
basically it's just testing and saying
what's the best threshold we just play
the threshold according to the type of
the data set
yeah all right nice so it's a some sort
of a heuristic method to make sure you
get the kind of uh yeah in this case
just in the presentation I said like
explicitly it's 0.2 in this case just to
make it clear to the audience but of
course it's not like explicit threshold
like we can say it build the threshold
around five percent of the results so
you can put the threshold with two
percent of the results and again well
playing with the threshold
okay very nice thanks for that
um there's a second question which I'll
bring up on screen uh by Marco Antonio
parent uh curious about the article on
iron and masking
okay I'm I'm not so sure I have a good
answer for that except Google it
because it's it's a bit tricky to use
masking with RNN so just Google uh using
masking with RNN Auto encoders and you I
think
yeah the top five results will be the a
good answer for him yeah I think it's
it's worthwhile moving your discussion
over to Discord and if anyone else has
come across this article that we can
share then that would be useful as well
um uh so we still have a couple of
minutes left and there is another
question
which I'll bring up one screen as well
by Morgan Mahood what does a good actor
look like
um I'm guessing this this question is
regarding the second experiment I made
I have no good answer to say how good
actor looks alive because I'm working
with another team that you know gave me
a bunch of good users so I can build a
model on
if we are talking about tax data sets a
good actor like a good sentence is just
a normal sentence and I'm I created the
bad users
the bed sentences and if you are looking
on the the second like the information
security experiment
you know I'm working in in the company
where we have
those examples uh and I can't share too
much but I worked with the team
and we're working together on those data
and they gave me the data and I'm not so
sure I can say more than that
yeah yeah obviously I guess it's a very
uh domain specific definition definitely
a domain specific yeah yeah excellent
all right uh thank you for that answer
um
are there any other questions you
probably have like one more minute
remaining
um before we can conclude
I guess that's a there's a good place to
to stop if anyone else has any questions
please hop on over to Discord and you
can ask your questions there uh LeRon uh
hopefully you're also on Discord and
then you can have some nice discussions
about about these um on the channel over
there thank you for hosting me yeah
thank you very much for your talk